welcome to this video for around six
yeah 16 coverage of Tom Memorial 2013
and I'm doing something rather than
coming here starting the video while one
game is still going but it is an awfully
long game and this video that I'm
recording now won't be that long
compared to to some others simply
because it is the hottest day of the
year here in Germany we've got above 30
degrees celsius which means like 90 plus
for a night it's damn hot here and i'm
just waiting for some friends to arrive
to go to the biergarten if you know what
I mean so hey I'm just doing a rather
quick review of today's games there was
some interesting things happening so um
let's get to to the action I'll show
briefly it's an awfully long game as
mentioned the game that is still running
just that you get an impression what was
happening that this is morose eviction
against kayaking two of the guys zone
near the end of the table um this only
shows that the tournament is damn strong
those players at the end all right let's
see um what happened to you we had an
ouzo and Queen c2 was played by moral
you often place that he also plays
before and all kinds of them thanks but
if he goes d for you sometimes place the
Quincy to line d5 and tiered is Queen d5
this is slightly uncommon line nowadays
but it is still interesting it
immediately attacks the default point i
cannot draw an ero cm this is annoying
we check
actually just a second here it's not
working this is bad cannot draw an arrow
cm when it's still I think I need to
copy that I don't know how this is
working alright so we need to do this
without any errors I'm sorry um yeah
black is playing Queen f5 this is quite
an interesting idea of the ideas if
white takes on f-5e takes f 5 gives
black good lights crowd control queen
bee three and 96 so after a couple of
moves we reach a position where like has
given up this Bishop so why just got the
the two bishops on c3 and f1 and the
white has also expanded with h3 and g4
9550 to get to be honest them I don't
like blacks position here at all which
is in a way due to the fact that I'm um
yeah I well known bishop pair addict
what can i say i don't really like this
position blacks counterplay seems very
awake to me and white is got the 2 b's
and in fact it's played this in a very
interesting manner group g1 covering the
the bishop on g2 so that they are
discoveries threaten all of 95 and after
f6 g5 we see why the rook went to g1 and
why why didn't castle the king is fine
only one he can use the look on g1
nicely and after a couple of moves we
got more trades and in fact transposed
into an endgame we're still the two
bishops are an important factor in fact
why this is just better here there's no
doubt about that it's just a matter how
firm how good is the position after g6
here moral decided to give up the bush
yeah but he's got something in return we
would see that this structure is also
quite favorable for white he's got the
strong efore bishop and b5 is not so
great the bishop it's only there to
defend a 4 and yeah put a little bit of
pressure on e to with this point can
easily move so the b5 bishop is a little
bit like piece that is pointing into
thin air while this efore Bishop helps
why to push h4 h5 just one thing after a
couple of moves we have this on change
of the structure where black is left
with the h-bomb but this is not really a
strong passport this is a weakness and
in fact white got some some pressure
against this one and won it but black
got counterplay and if you look at this
just a couple of moves later we really
don't need to check it in so much detail
just a couple of moves later this was
exchanged and this was exchanged now we
see that it's very difficult for whites
to make any substantial progress here
the upon is not the bond that you can
just push home I mean this c4 Bishop now
is rather good it's protected by b5 it
has a look at at the e6 square and then
in fact the my main issue is that
White's king is on d2n doesn't really
help so it went on for some more moves
fact white good play this tactic to
transpose into a rook endgame and then
at the end we reached this position and
it was really a draw like two or three
months ago right here unless it's still
a draw King see success the only move
this is not an analysis I mean this
hasn't been played yet kinsey sicks is
probably the only move and how is right
going to make any progress I don't
really see it maybe rook be 50 this
actually has been played maybe we'll be
five King before but Lex got like can
also try to go for counter check against
be to pawn as I actually still think
it's a draw but we will seem somewhat
later maybe it's possible that they
shuffle around for a while so I didn't
want to wait until this happened so this
is why i started the video even when
there was this versus game still running
ok let's get to the finish games we had
them and drankin against Mammadyarov and
this time i even get to draw some arrows
hooray so a scotch game with Bishop c5
this is some one of the main lines
Knight f6 being the other and hack
Bishop c5 is a move that I never played
in tournaments as I think I'm not a no
protection particularly reason but it is
a pretty decent line um on wrecking out
took on c6 a team of yarrow from play to
move that only recently had come into
fashion he played be takes c6 the
traditional main move always has been
Queen to have six threatening an
intermediate made here so wyd cannot
save the night but then winner three had
post some problems in the in the
last couple of years where this kind of
end game on proved to be somewhat tricky
from like this is also why the move B
takes c6 has come into into fashion a
bit and well I know the structure
because I often play and have
recommended this evening a video here
this line where black flicks in this
check and then the capture this is of
course somewhat similar in the game here
we have the pawn still here so i have
always this position response III with
the night stop being able to go to c3
this position was always considered to
be somewhat better for wide but practice
doesn't really confirm that it seems
that like it's in pretty decent shape we
see this funny Queen h4 move threatening
them ATM and why them can only reply not
the only move but it's the the most
sensible looking move Queen to f3 and
now night to h6 this is what idea of the
screen edge form with the queen is
actually well placed on each for it's an
aggressive square and night to age 62 g
oops this is a bit much to default serve
as an idea or Bishop g4 if you want so
it's an active position Knight g4 is the
main idea also allowing Knight to e5
this is also may be more interesting
than Knight to f6 in comparison also
because it leaves open the possibility
of plague f7f 5 Bishop e3 yeah this is a
strong bishop so it is exchanged but
this of course somewhat strengthen the
black structure Queen g3 app it's hard
to not exchange the Queen really this is
really an annoying piece so the Queen's
have traded and now I five seeing you
see this is one point of getting the
night to h6 quickly having the
possibility to play F 705 and exchanging
this strong porn
form so that in fact in this position
black evening the one with an extra
central pawn so I think we can already
conclude that this position is quite a
success for black probably and he
reached them quite easy equality it's
not more but it's it's quite decent so G
for this was mostly to keep the night
out of the game so at first i thought
that isn't black aight aight here i mean
you've got a better structure there are
two islands against three islands so
until there are somewhat so some weak
spots yet White's position with much
like those squares for instance there
all week but yeah black needs to spend
some time with the night you know this
is the problem you need some time to
have it relocated and the knighthood d4
is even even harder to achieve which
would be very nice um and in fact we see
that in in the game Mammadyarov went to
two before with the rook good good
interesting idea activating the peace
and only then activating the night later
the idea but white managed to get some
counter play with the rookie 7d form
mighty form and rooks the ATM doesn't
want to give away the sea porn so easily
and now a five this is a really good
move the idea is to make this beep on
moose like taking and then after rookie
one and the possible 95 white has
activated all pieces this is a pretty
good now good compensation and white now
even gets to e6 but it's not a big deal
I mean in terms of equality for black he
always has this counter play against the
B 2 95 @ XD 3 with the check so what
needs to react place
94 and night f7 back yeah no white took
on c7 getting a pawn back and black now
with a for a 3 trying to get the UM
breakthrough going here on the queenside
I think the position is rather draw
actually rook takes c6 95 group to c7
and now g5 the tactical move try to
dislodge this night and then take d3
night moved and now like went for this
funny move with getting rid of this
active rook yeah this is the idea yeah
like gets it back so whoopsie tools
plate night XD 3 checked and now the
exchange led to a really draw an endgame
wider defender to the vporn but it at
the end went to a look at game where we
are a white also sssg to weakness so
this was traded off not even a way
genders and it's a dead wrong so it
seems to me a very correct draw
sometimes it's just happens both players
play decently and it's the draw the
remarkable thing is this this opening
idea which is important for Scotch
players on one in five players that we
take c6 and queen age for might be a
good term antidote against this capture
on c6 all right um next game is galfond
cards and here we see that Magnus is
playing the Queens gambit with night BTW
sevens a bit of an ancient line but he
has some played this before in fact he
plated against Gelfond in the candidates
and one of the early rounds I think
round 3 if i'm not mistaken and carlsen
actually won a nice very important game
in that game girl from played Bishop g5
and after c6e 325 we got
I Cambridge erm springs in this game
however play today there was Bishop f4
plate this is some of course one of the
main moves against this Bishop e7 which
is the classical line of the of the
Queens gambit you should a floor castles
and so on the night is not on these
services that the difference here with
97 Bishop f4 and black actually has the
chance to do something else you can take
on c4 and one point of this might be
that Knight b6 is covering this porn
later and also that this structure with
capturing and a 6b five quite often this
Bishop is not so well placed on a phone
it's really not really helpful piece for
white and we see that in the game after
a four he played Bishop d6 interesting I
never saw this move exactly or this idea
exactly in this position it is a common
idea but normal would have been c5 which
would also be quite okay for like but
Bishop d6 is is a good idea trying to
get rid of one minor piece and yeah what
is why it's supposed to do um sometimes
you even can allow like to take here and
recapture with people but I'm not sure
that this is a position where I'm this
is really helpful something like this is
probably probably quite okay for black
you cannot expect to be better this is
not a problem it's a very well-known
pawn structure even back from the 1920s
and sergey's famous games of Rubinstein
and a lackin or nothin okay okay but
girl phantom was obviously aware of this
he went for something else he just took
t6 that Roxy for
the kind of quibids simple method that
should be good enough for a position
where white is very safe and can hardly
ever lose and now cuz went for d65
probably it's hard to avoid this in the
long run and it's not a problem reading
if you look at this d5 now be six the
thing is black has a very
straightforward and simple setup and
after this setup it's very difficult for
white to reach anything take a look this
is the setup Bishop to d7 and now just
double on on the C file on exchange on
the sea for this kind of position arises
almost back for us because they are no
though no more porn breaks in the
position lucky for you five the very
hard to play and the C file just sees
the total clearance iam and this kind of
position here is of course a bit very
very small bit better for white because
this Bishop is better than the c8 bishop
however to make anything concrete out of
this is an entirely different matter we
see that after a couple of more moves
here the Queen side is closed and couple
of moves later we even had green trade
yeah this is just a little bit of
strengthening by both sides gaining some
some useful space and now we had the
Queen's off so how to assess this
position um you see that the pawns are
completely symmetrical this here is
completely symmetrical on the on the
king's island in the center here White
has a space advantage but he's got at
least on paper the worst bishop because
he's got the points and light squares
but this is not the main problem this
Bishop on on c8 probably never would get
around to ever attack the F up on the
only thing that white is some doing for
him here and this is something is that
this points these pawns in d4 and d5 um
that the d5 pawn is on a light squared
can be attacked by the bishop or at
least can be put that can be put some
pressure on the spawn and this is the
only idea that white has left in the
position we see actually that it it it
plays a role in the game a couple of
moves later here girl from played on
with F for which is of course is a good
move there's no other break really left
that it's that is any promising so f4
and in fact I think now council played
Bishop to f7 and he played this rather
quickly at much more time I'd actually
believe this is a mistake this move he
should have taken on f4 and this
probably transposes to the game but
after here after here no girl front
actually had more than seven minutes on
the clock and T I think galphin could
have gotten a pretty substantial
advantage with f5 and strangely enough
he didn't play it this is a hydrant
really surprising because it's the
effort obviously that it's the clearly
thematic nuclear to to dislodge the six
porn so that you get at d5 to check it
and it's really hard to see how black
and white
losing a porn here the only line that
doesn't lose a pawn instantly is I think
if I've but it's not great I really
don't see what black is supposed to play
if it takes for example just just for
argument's sake something like this it's
pretty awful this should be three eddie
before coming white is just winning here
black cannot take and i don't really see
a move what is so black supposed to do
something like this you can also just
just plain a similar matter i can
actually i can actually do that this is
quite quite the same and white is again
winning a 50 things would have gotten
cousin into huge trouble but strangely
enough girlfriend didn't play that he
played this first maybe he miscalculated
something here because now council could
take and play 96 and this seems to hold
its it's really it's a very fragile
construction for black but it seems to
hold and i think also if i read this
correctly cars are also said in the
press conference that he thought them
the position was very very very jewish
and pretty much dead around and 130 and
then he said that he made some
inaccurate move so that girlfriend had
something and then he managed to
equalize it again somehow what i think
is that here after this this is the
difference compared to not allowing the
exchange on f4 that black can actually
activate this this piece and after that
i don't really see anything that white
can do to play for win and also the
computer doesn't I mean I only had very
little time to prepare this and the comp
already goes down to something new
here black uses this this pin as a
defensive resource and it seems that
with precise plane and cousin showed
that this really should be at all yeah
this in fact is is a perpetual quite a
funny perpetual with white having no
opportunity to get out of all of the
checks and still cover the hit the
knight on d5 so bit of a lucky game with
this one spot where um with lucky from
Magnus I mean we're gelfand I think
could have gotten a big edge here this
f5 with the opportunity and this was a
big game girlfriend wasn't plus two
before this game and if he would have
won this hmm plus 3 looks like like a
real big one for him but ok it's a just
ended in a draw um ok we have kawana
against kramnik this was actually a
fairly interesting despite this opening
where you yeah cannot help but yeah
cannot help but ask yourself on my mini
again the ending ok and we get the
ending the famous broaden wall ending
its 357 look T 1 yeah I cannot really
tell so much about this the opening what
I can can tell us that what karana is
doing it is quite interesting here's
some delaying the Knight c3 move which
is affect the main moves in this
position here instead of h3 93's the by
far the most popular move here and here
black has this position way can play all
kinds of moves we should be 17 8 h 6 and
so on the main line the main position of
the burn
koala is delaying this Knight c3 move
and instead plays h3 rock t 1 and now g4
so he's playing a very very direct
attack on the Kings side and it's still
quite interesting play knight to e7 my
g5 ok not much of a choice this is hain
black needs to cover it this is a one of
the ideas of bishop this happen to have
this covering move it's a bit agni of
course but yeah it's a it's a matter of
long-term play and concrete play white
is trying for some concrete play on the
kingside long-term there are always the
two bishops so if black manages to
coordinate his pieces his position and
it's not going under here well against
this direct play on the kingside he's
been pushing her for now if he's not
directly rolled over yeah the King side
black is in good shape with the two
bishops and it seems look at the clocks
they were both in their preparation age
5 + f5 very sharp yeah Kramnik took it
not much of a choice Andrew cage for
this is very straightforward and at
first you think what the hell is so high
doing isn't he just losing this pawn and
what about this pawn in fact there is
some there's an idea here King f2 is
very very interesting wyd is threatening
now to just use the King to protect this
advanced structure so Black has not much
of a choice really it's pretty much
forced to to to capture and this is what
he did OOP takes a g4 and now look to h1
intending look h8 quite quite a
remarkable concept trying to catch those
pieces on the on the background where
they are
absolutely not coordinated white also
had the chance the opportunity to play
Knight 2h7 which is completely bizarre
looking but it's interesting it detects
this Bishop and how how to use to how do
you protect it in fact black can play
night x f 59 f 8b 6 black can really
play funny enough with a piece down and
i only had a brief look with the
computer and in fact the computer gives
black sufficient compensation here which
seems absolutely strange to me but them
it the lines were pretty convincing
black is playing c5 and Bishop c6 and
why does taking ages to get this piece
back into play h7 g5 and back again and
it takes a really long time and in the
meantime moves like c5 Bishop c6
threaten rook g2 there's 94 c 2 and all
kinds of active ideas for black so it
seems to be possible yeah come on up
late rook age one actually thought a bit
about that look h1 and chrome Nick took
on f5 obviously he's still in his prep
which is still a rather amazing okay but
he's in his preparation he took their
book h8 we should check king of three
and now look to g1 and left still in
this prep sacrificing a bishop and the
rook so after this and the capture can
we can do a count and we see that right
it's a rock up White has an extra look
for just one pawn and yeah how to assess
the position it seems that it's still
okay for black and this is already I
mean even if you don't invest any time
analyzing yourself you see that chronic
played this out of his preparation so we
pretty much know that it is
a but in fact the simple threat night
situ and takes a one is some so strong
that white is actually forced to very
quickly get to m2m to a draw here before
attacking this and ce4 intending to play
c5 winning another piece and now black
must play c5 to prevent that now after a
three there's this idea but black can
give this check and in fact here this
series of check checks is a perpetual
and they agree to draw you see that
Kramnik actually spent some time here
before this before he actually decided
on the on the perpetual he can look here
after a 3 has spent lots of time and it
seems that he didn't find anything
better he probably had had prepared this
line and just concluded okay if
everything else fails I can make the
draw here which is not too bad against a
world-class player and maybe I even have
something better but it seems there is
nothing better the computer also says
it's a draw and recommends the series of
checks so drawn between those two
Kramnik is still at the bottom of the
table with minus 2 okay and now let's go
to the main game of today's round I'll
not against Nakamura the world champion
against the US number 1 Tikal Nakamura
now come without having an excellent
tournament by now winning three games in
the last couple of rounds he started
with loss and then three three wins and
his plates of excellent just along the
way and now he's playing black against
the world champion island had lost
yesterday very very yeah depressing loss
against Carson so let's see what what
happens here
we got a rillo passyunk are playing a 5
so not the night off but in five and in
fact he played g6 yeah which is rather
predictable it's always playing the way
he I really don't remember him playing
anything else and okay ng6 g6 x nakamura
which is an interesting sideline and in
fact it's a sideline that i have studied
to myself quite a while ago but i
concluded that i don't like it so much
because of from this line this line I
didn't like take and Bishop g5 if i
remember correctly is what I what I
didn't like it leads to an end game
after Bishop e7 it's not it's not the
end of the world but this kind of
position is oops this is the position
that is coming up and I thought this was
a bit too depressing for black it's very
solid I mean black can play this no
doubt but if I want a solid position in
the way I can play the stuff that I
already play like the chi going also so
while I didn't like that so much but
this didn't happen in the game and I
just cancelled yeah white can also play
stuff like this which is interesting
gambit style or can also play ac3 and d4
of course which is the main line but
castles Bishop g7 now after c3 could
transpose to two main line now the
camera though played 86 just interesting
um let the normal reply now would be
Bishop a4 and I'm pretty surprised that
Anna not to go and see 6 I mean he's
very well known as having a soft spot
for Knights compared to bishops he's
probably probably from the world class
and the player who by far um most
frequently plays with Knights against
bishops um to be honest I really don't
like
the capture here but okay I'm as
mentioned more than once always a fan of
the bishop so it feels to me that giving
up the two bishops so early should be
quite ok for like we can look at this
position here just this position um and
um yeah for me this is a good bishop and
this is another good Bishop which at the
moment admittedly it doesn't do so much
I cannot really post it anywhere um
anyway actively but okay you still have
it for later and what I'm not sure of
here is what exactly White's plan is is
obviously not worse why cannot view
versus got a center it's got good
development and it's a very healthy
position but I'm not so sure what
White's plan is here it's probably still
I'm around an equal an equal position
but the plan what's the plan for black I
always no i care but the two bishops i
only need to trade down some things and
i will have a good end game but i'm not
so sure what why this doing here um in
fact in this position as black i got
some comments that that lady I sometimes
ask them the audience to just pass the
video for a couple of seconds and try to
find a good move yourself this is one of
those positions where I can ask you
again for black think about a move here
what should black play it sir it's a
positional move a strategical idea it's
not a technical thing okay you can
already guess that there's no tactics in
there um what should like do here I mean
you have more than one move but there's
one important feature of the position
that can be addressed by a moose which i
think is the strongest in this position
think about it I'll be quiet for a
couple of seconds that you can easily
pass the video
yeah all right the the good and strong
move that Nakamura here plate is the
move h6 this is very strong the ideas to
play g6g five and then night to g6
because he's looking at his pieces and
asking myself okay what is my worst
piece and the worst piece but black is
the night on in seven it doesn't do
anything it only looks at controlled
squares and it's in the way of rook
putting pressure on the porn and in
general the night is not doing anything
here so is playing age six ng5 to
activate the night to clear the e-file
make those kinds of moves possible later
and even play g5g form to make use of
this hook on age three so HD 6mg five is
a very good idea positional idea and
something that is often difficult to to
play in a game that you play yourself
because it costs time you spend two
moves age six and g5 but then it really
improves the pieces at the end the night
on on g6 is just much better than only
seven so a very strong move but it's
it's hard to play I mean in a practical
game um so don't be afraid if you spot a
good idea play it or you think of you if
you think about something and you think
it's a good idea you should be M
confident enough to play it okay well I
decentralizing pieces I actually would
have liked more to play rook e1 and what
do you want but and i'm not i'm not
entirely sure what what's happening here
to be honest define yeah this is one of
the ideas that that that white can can
go for but of course if you look at this
g5g five this is an excellent diagonal
whites plane s we see this now with this
with might be five and a possible d6
bush but it seems that
this is really not leading to to
anything not to anywhere black Scott
g-form discounter play only possible
because of the Jeep on push and now the
bishop is developed here nicely putting
up the pin why not play Bishop to d2 to
defend this night so that you can
recapture with with the peace queen to
d7 and now rook see one I don't really
understand what would see one is doing I
thought rook e1 root g one still to have
the pawns draft the rooks behind behind
the pawns I prefer that but I think the
real issue is coming now I mean c6 took
and now I think the next move by
meyerland really seems to be a mistake
he played Bishop to c3 and I think I'm
and also this view is supported by the
comp that he really should play hookie
one him and trying to correct the
replacement um i already am quite
clearly prefer black and the two bishops
are strong I mean no doubt about that
and black has got ideas to activate the
night as well for instance if you think
about a move like Bishop c3 black has
always 9f form but I think rookie one
was post better he played this bishops
III move trying to of course exchange
the the long diagonal Bishop here but it
just has got one problem like and take
here and damage the pawn structure GTX
and rook the eight played here also
night f4 was interesting intending Queen
to g6 and maybe this was even better
it's very difficult actually for y2 to
play this position it seems that the
best movie has roop these six everything
else seems to lose instantly and after
Queen c8 there's a double threat with
Queen age 42 g to mate and night oops 92
to winning the exchange in fact black
wins the exchange now you need to play
that attacking the night and then black
can grab the exchange and this should be
quite a big edge from black white still
hangs on a bit he's got active pieces
left and the king is relatively secure
but it seems that it should be an
excellent from black however he played
rock do you want a rock the eighth which
keeps some advantage of course still
because this is structure is simply bad
and now I'm defended by exchanging to
Gandhi aid and rook to d1 but the
problem is if you look at this now this
is just not a good end game black has
got the edge pole as a passer this pawns
are pretty much not mobile and it's very
difficult to to make any any big head
way for white or black I always got the
h-bond is still white still has
defensive resources but it's a it seems
to be a very tricky now he played um
Queen d5 and after the exchange and this
exchange in fact the computer points out
the move King f8 and assess black is
instantly winning it may be more precise
than what Nakamura played but he kept
them an advantage anyhow like 935 taking
this one white activated 936 it's not so
great to take on every now there's
something more important to do get your
king into the game king edge to hear
white could have played air form as a
possible alternative but after night d 3
it seems that black is also in great
shape at the end there's always oops
this move attacking the apron and why
now can capture here of course but now
like approaches with the king and at the
end will win the pound so this is
excellent for black in fact winning yeah
this is what was played and it seems
really that this position here quite
interesting here the night is trap now
what needs to resort to some tricks yeah
yeah you can barely keep the other night
the problem is though that the resulting
endgame is just terrible black king
black king in weights and win spawns and
you still have the edge porn it's enough
yeah sorry had a small technical glitch
here in effect black has an extra point
anyway because the edge porn is just as
good as an extra porn because these are
two but the Joey counts as one and
blacks king is so active so in fact the
game finished rather quickly with
Nakamura winning the sea porn and now
pushing the sea porn and here are non
resigned so a second loss in a row for
the world champion and that camera
winning yet again and now he's really
leading this tournament alone with plus
three he's looking to get an excellent
result and pretty much everything
depends now on the game in the thing it
depend alternate round against Carlton
where Magnus certainly will try to win
two to catch Nakamura but even this um
in this is just one game there was two
more games left for Nakamura but he's
playing excellently in this in this
event now and has excellent chances to
win this but also on the the standings
is quite amazing with anand and Kramnik
being the the two to two people at the
bottom and a quick quick update on LA
on sorry Mauro against kayaking on this
100 they agreed to a draw and we had we
had this rook endgame and like held on
too good to two da Pole and yellow it's
no use to study this at them at at this
present time it ended in a draw on move
100 so thanks for watching i'll be
uploading this video now and i'm off in
seconds to the beer garden thanks and
enjoy the summer if you have similar
temperatures as we have fear by